let's get to it though I just love a
great show and great music y'all uh
let's get to it though it's Oscar season
so that time of year when studios are
releasing their most groundbreaking
movies a powerful new film named Monica
is getting a lot of Oscar buzz and next
year could actually make history which
is super cool it deals with issues of
dementia and aging parents it also Stars
Patricia Clarkson no relation but I love
her and Trace leet who could be the
first transgender woman nominated for
best actress and my audience got a
chance to see it what did y'all think
did you like it you like
it all right well and since it's
transgender awareness week we thought
it's the perfect time to talk about this
incredible film with its Stars everybody
please give a warm welcome to trace leet
and Patricia
[Applause]
Clarkson
[Music]
we were like you are your jeans yeah
it's a jeans day I a red eye and it was
running late love I'm I'm just I'm kind
of like hooker mom I have
no oh my God we have to be related no I
wish Kelly Kelly I have to tell you I I
so would love to lie and say I'm related
You Are So Divine beautiful
extraordinary are you're
so but
wait if you heard me sing one note you
would know immediately I am not related
but anyway I yeah we are not related but
I I think that we are I'm my mother
wishes we could claim you she says you
can claim me I love you you're so gifted
um well did y'all meet before filming
Monica did you know each other no we
didn't no we met a party an em an Emmy
party yeah that's right but we had both
been cast okay very and I saw her across
the crowded room and I thought oh my God
she's the most beautiful woman in this
whole room and I'm her
mother and now you're we're sisters you
just get gting family members but yes
yes I play everybody's mother beautiful
mother sister yes I mean I want to be
everybody's mother or sister yeah yeah
but we all are connected I do believe
that um but Monica is pretty personal
for you this film is pretty personal
right oh yeah I mean every trans story
is personal for me um Monica I mean
there's so many monikas out there I feel
like our journey uh with with our
families and just where we fall in the
world and how the world makes space for
us or doesn't make space for us is
always going to be a fight that we're
going to have to fight at least in my
lifetime probably um but this movie it
you know it's it's for the girls it's
for the dolls it's for the fem Queens
it's for the trans women that
I've been waiting for so long for their
stories to be told it centers on her
it's not centered on someone else it's
it's through her lens which is very
different usually you know if there's a
trans person involved in a movie they're
they're not the protagonist they're not
the centerpiece um so that's why this
film is so special but that's why I I
said yes faster to this film than any
film I've ever done in my very long
career yeah because it was it kind of
still very emotional for me it was not
lost on me Kelly that that it would give
an extraordinary transgender actress the
lead I said I'll be your backup singer
any day I knew how important this film
was yeah tell everybody like give like a
kind of a synopsis what's the plot for
everyone so Monica has been living life
on her own for 20 years or so and um her
mother is in her last day
and she makes a decision to go home and
see what it's giving you know and see
you know see what there so much with the
tone of giving that was awesome yeah see
what see what's happening back back
where you know her roots and see uh if
there's a connection there with the
family or I don't know I mean her mother
is struggling with memory loss and and
brainery cancer I mean I'm in my last
last month of yeah and I don't know who
she is because she's transitioned and I
think she's hospice and so I'm not
happy that this woman is here and it's a
p of a mother and a
daughter coming to terms with their
lives but which is relatable for many
actually oh it is about family I mean
it's ultimately about forgiveness and
love and hope and every family
experiences that it's about it's a it is
it's about about unconditional love a
mother learning to love a child
unconditionally and a child spending the
rest of her life with the love of her
mother yeah I've had several people come
up to me that were not trans that have
just dealt with um death and caring for
their loved ones in their last days
particularly their parents um had an
adop e come up to me who reconnected
with their birth parent later in life
and they were also moved by this story
so there's definitely a universal theme
there uh beyond the trans of it all oh
definitely I mean it it it will take you
far it really and you know your be Josh
closy plays our you know my beautiful
son your brother you know it's just got
these great great actors Ariana baratza
the great great great Mexican actress
it's just it's filled with really
beautiful performances and it's shot on
real film too
yeah such I've never looked worse never
looked
sometimes I'm against High
death yeah right I'm like you're too
close you can see it all we are
celebrating transgender awareness week
this week and we are honored to have
these two women here to talk about their
claimed movie Monica so I have to talk
about this is it was it the Venice Film
Festival that y'all got an 11 minute
standing ovation 11 and a half oh my go
cuz that's a long time like think about
it if we said here for 11 minutes yeah
it would be uncomfortable if you
applauded us for 11 and a half well it
would make our lives but yes I mean but
she was the first transgender actress to
ever lead a film in the history of the
Venice Film
Festival yeah um what what have you seen
from people that have seen the film like
what have you seen as the reaction from
like the trans Community oh my goodness
I I get like long letters on uh social
media just from all over the world um
trans people writing me telling me Oh my
God this the first time I saw myself in
a movie you know as represented yeah
right um it's just so much bigger it's
it's ah it's just there's so much at
stake for us right now there's been
bills introduced this year uh like
legislation that are just trying to make
our lives our lives harder or erase us
all together um so something like this I
don't know the visib visibility brings
um hopefully brings Humanity to our
lives hopefully you know if someone
doesn't know a trans person in their own
day-to-day lives maybe they can watch a
movie like this and see Monica's heart
and see her mother's heart and see uh
that we're deserving of love and and see
the talent and you know everything that
that we can bring um to this world and
to this industry and yeah I mean it's
been really moving so I think the the
message I get from all over that's what
really keeps me keeps me going going
look timing is So Divine Right like it's
what a perfect time to have something
like this for people to watch like even
if you aren't affected like you said
directly impacted in your everyday life
to see what is happening outside of your
circle is so important it's just
important for us to progress as humans
like in that sense but um our next guest
is an icon and it's an honor to have her
here today so let's bring her out now
her podcast is called the lever
show it's available wherever you get
your podcast everybody please welcome Le
[Applause]
Co scoot down and we'll come in well you
look fabulous thank you y'all got the
wear black memo and we got the wear
jeans memo I like this so you got to you
got to see Monica so what are your
thoughts oh my God yes yeah oh I love
this film so much
and I just wanted to take a moment and
take a breath because what I love about
being an artist and being an actor is
that I think art at its
best reaffirmed what it means to be
human for us a beautiful film a song
reaffirms for us as human beings as
viewers what it means to be human and
helps us to understand our experiences
in our lives better and maybe to work
through something and I think Monica
operates at that highest of levels of
art where I watched it and I understood
something about being human about
alienation I think that the way the film
is shot we and the way we linger with
Monica we understand that that there's
this distance between her and how the
world sees her her wanting to make a
connection but it just keeps falling
apart with the world around her and then
with the person who should she should be
closest to the most there's this
distance and we and then they don't see
us and can't see us and all of us want
to just be deeply seen and known
everyone wants that and I think that's
what this movie is about and it
illustrates it and tells the story
visually and through these incredible
performances in such a way where I feel
like it's a Sacred Space what that is
created in this film
of understanding the complicated
relationship of alienation distance
longing to be seen and known and then
the hope the glimpse of recognition of
recognition of seeing of understanding I
why one of the reason I took the film
because I think that's what it is is it
is about unconditional love it's about
all of us finding unconditional law and
everyone searching for everybody wants
that so with anti-lgbtq laws being
passed in many states what do you all
hope this movie does for the awareness
of trans people well for me what I am
aware of is that what the way that these
laws um have been passed is that they've
it's been a really um um anti-trans
folks have done a really good job of
dehumanizing us they have um reduced us
to Transitions and body parts and it
they've done a really good job of making
us less than human and when you can
dehumanize people you can take away
their rights you can commit violence
against them what Monica does is deeply
humanizes a trans woman at the center of
a story we are human beings deserving of
Love deserving of Rights and respect and
it's really about a rehumanizing process
that has to happen in relationship to
trans people and great storytelling is a
beautiful way to do
that
goodness I I just I I've said this
before what I don't understand in our
country we have a great country when we
really live up to the real values of it
amen people people cross rivers and
mountains and they cross oceans they
risk their children's lives to come to
this country to flee persecution why do
we turn around and persecute our
[Music]
own what's your hope you know playing
Monica like what's your hope what do
what do you hope this does I I mean well
of course you know I hope it humanizes
us but I also hope and hope that it
opens doors for for more stories so that
um because you know we're not a monolith
there's so many there's so many trans
stories that need to be told and we kind
of we need we need uh we need to knock
on that glass ceiling we need to open up
space and um it's really hard for a film
like this to get funding uh and so I
know that whatever comes after this is
going to have their work cut out for
them um but if this film does well maybe
it'll be a little easier for whoever
comes next and can I add to that for all
the folks out there who are allies thank
you for doing this show Kelly yeah um
this is the action this is the work the
people who say that was going to be my
question what do you what do you advise
people do the people who say their
allies and who stand with us need to put
their money where their mouths are that
they need to
elevate they need to elevate our stories
fun trans projects I you know I I'm so
blessed in my work but I and I just did
shot a show it is really hard to get a
trans show by a trans creator with a
trans lead made a TV show a movie it's
nearly impossible and with all the
backlash now it's even more difficult
right with everything that happened with
targeting um um but light earlier this
year corporations are afraid right
they're scared and if you say you're
with us now is the time to really show
up and put your money where your mouth
is fund projects support us fight
against this anti- um lgbtq plus
legislation and lift up the real lived
experiences of trans people and actual
trans people and bring us to the table
absolutely w hopefully this is
progression like hopefully people
watching this people are affected they
go home they tell their family members
they tell their friends and hopefully
that's what happens and people actually
showing up like you said um well Billy
Porter um was on the show recently I
love him and he said this about dealing
with the backlash against the lgbtq plus
Community what we have to do who are the
people in the positions to make the
change is understand that the change has
already happened that's why the push
back is so severe yeah yeah yeah like
what are your thoughts on that statement
that's it's it's exactly right a few
years ago I was I was I I um I was a ail
for um there lot of trans um women had
been murdered in in a short span of time
and I was a ail in Los Angeles and I
said it's the best of times it's the
worst of times at that moment we could
go to there was a film with um soring
transv Port Authority there was at the
can film festival um Lena blooms in the
cover of Sports Illustrated trans people
are everywhere in terms of visibility
and we're being murdered
disproportionately and there all these
anti-lgbtq plus laws are beautiful
visibility the beautiful lights that
trans people have inside of us are
shining brightly and we're getting more
opportunities and we're more visible and
because of that visibility the backlash
has happened people are afraid or scared
and so these laws are happening and this
propaganda is happening and so I think
we just have to understand that's what's
happening understand that there's a
dehumanizing process going going on
understand that we're being
propagandized and
then come with love come with love and
Humanity to each other understand with
Open Hearts understand this beautiful
light should be shining and that and
that we're it all has to be about love
you know because they think the fear the
fear that people are they're using fear
and people are afraid and we're we a lot
of people don't understand trans folks
or you know don't know a p a trans
person personally but we're all human
and we proceed with love love then I
think we can cor as that is fall into
place I believe that in my whole Spirit
as corny as he is if we can proceed with
love first and empathy it's all good
it's all
good be sure to check out the movie
Monica it's on demand please support it
and you can also find the lever Cox Show
wherever you get your
[Music]
podcast
[Applause]
thank you guys y'all have a great night
I'm going
home